so i have a theory that every mom has a  childhood phase that she kind of  specializes in and then a childhood  phase that she has no natural skills for  i don't know anything about babies and  toddlers nothing like having six babies  in eight years only taught me that i i  don't know about babies they're just so  confusing to me they're so cute i love  them but i am overwhelmed and confused  by babies but i am really enjoying the  teen years the tween and teen ages that  is more for me like wrestling with  really deep heavy difficult subjects  i'll stay up with a kid till 4am talking  about that but when they're a toddler  like screaming for 15 minutes because  you looked at their cracker that's where  i'm like i'm out i don't know what to do  with this someone get me a nanny i need  downton abbey like i need to ring the  bell like where's the downstairs staff  coming to help me with this like i can't  i just can't so i'm really enjoying  these ages